money for russia and nukes for iran
thanks to a prez with no brain and no
plan
as the washington free beacon reports
the new iran agreement would let russia
cash in on 10 billion dollar contract to
build nuclear sites
russia and the biden white house
confirmed that the new nuke deal
includes carveouts that will wave
sanctions on both countries so much for
those sanctions huh meanwhile u.s energy
secretary jennifer granholm views the
war in ukraine as an opportunity to act
on clean energy
this crisis
in uh in europe and the crisis our
allies are facing and the reduction of
supply of
natural gas and oil from russia
creates a moment that we should be
acting we talk about electrification
obviously
it's not just about transportation it's
about
homes and
making sure that we
wean ourselves off of fossil fuels
using a war to wean ourselves off fossil
fuels i haven't seen such bizarre
priorities since michael moore bought
cologne
that is good
meanwhile morale among russian forces
are reportedly dropping faster than a
baby held by cat
it's no surprise according to the new
york times they're getting cream more
than 7 000 russian troops have already
been killed and the pentagon says as
more die their will to fight diminishes
especially the dead ones
all right joey i haven't talked to you
about this since it started
and i have been extremely
dedicated to being skeptical about
what's coming out of these countries
whether what's real versus what's
propaganda because i don't want to be
sold into a war the way i was with iraq
the problem is i think i'm changing i
think that what's coming out is
influencing me and making me think that
ukraine could win can you just tell me
what's going on
am i right to be cautiously optimistic
am i falling for the stuff i told other
people not to fall for
do i still have my youthful good looks
at 57.
your hair looks nice thank you yeah i'll
give you help man yeah he called me
jonathan for some
reason anyway um
i guess what i guess what bothers me
about this the most is when i went to
iraq in 2007-8 if you ask me why i was
there i would say so that guy and that
gal can come home right but that's as
much as i could believe it right i'd
already known by that point how much
was involved in that war and i willingly
went happily went as a united states
marine when i went to afghanistan in
2010 there was a little bit more
understanding of why i was there but we
had been there for ten years or uh nine
and a half years ten years and um and if
you ask me then while i was there it'd
be like i'm gonna take these bombs apart
so that those two can go home and all
these villagers that have been living in
war for too long have a chance at life
it was never about the mission though
right and so when i hear people say
stuff like the troops are just
downtrodden the russian troops are down
trotting they don't believe in the fight
i don't know that's true because i know
my bros fought of war for 20 years and
because of what came on the airwaves we
believed in it and really didn't have a
clue about the politics of it and so so
it's hard for me to buy everything hook
line and sinker so i've taken a step
back because i hosted fox and friends
and told the world that 13 people on
snake island died and um and i and and i
watched zielinski tell the world that uh
a russian rocket could make a nuclear
power plant turn into a nuclear bomb and
i know those things aren't true now
right but with that being said if i were
zielinski i'd be doing the same thing
yes propaganda is persuasion and so i
think what americans are struggling with
is you can want ukraine to win this war
you can understand that russia is the
aggressor and the villain and is doing
vile things but also know that you might
not agree with zelinski on anything else
in life and that's okay yeah you get
what i'm saying like this is real world
this is before you have an opportunity
to argue about things like being woke or
or unfairness this is life and death and
i think people in this country don't get
to separate those things well enough
because the year the war we fought for
20 years touched very few of our 330
million lives
and so i think for me when it comes to
understanding what's coming in and i
don't mean to hog the conversation at
all the last thing i'll say is like
zolinski wants these planes i'm a little
bit skeptical of that i understand war
enough to know what they need is ground
to air defense that can reach high
altitude which prevents long range and i
don't hear any reports over what air
force they have what capabilities they
have and how well they're using it and
there are a lot of reports and
intelligence reports coming out saying
they have plenty of planes so does
zelinski want the planes so that we are
more involved and to create that
opportunity perhaps and again i'm not
calling him a villain for it but if
biden's making this decision based on
that i'm not going to be biden up for it
either right okay
tyrus
are you
succumbing to what you're fighting
against right
i yes
you are because it's a steady drip yes
it's a constant drip it's just it hits
your forehead and hits you forward
you're like no no and after a while
you're like it's got to be true right
all this is coming out and you're a
human being
anytime you see a video of anyone being
carried out in a stretcher or a child
outside of a bomb department building
your first reaction is what the hell and
oh my god we have to do something if
you're any kind of a human being but
you chose to make this stand
and it was a very unpopular stand yeah
tell me and
so the pressure from that
and just the humanity of seeing what
we're seeing
i would be shocked if you didn't succumb
a little but the fact that you're still
asking the question i think is the most
important thing is we all have to ask
the question
because it looks to me like we're being
slowly drawn in
to this war we're getting pulled in and
you're a human being yeah i uh cat do
you believe that i'm a human being
because i don't i was gonna say that's
taking
i mean you you are
it's not about me though
it's about what what do you how do you
feel when you get when you're digesting
this information
well i think that obviously
like tyrus said you see these things you
think oh this is horrible i have to do
something but again you have to remind
yourself you don't want to end up doing
something that causes even more
destruction and causes even more people
to die
and just remember our track record with
getting involved in foreign conflicts as
of late
because there are real consequences
these to these things that need to be
considered
um
yeah
not so much for me right but for but
that's another thing i'm not gonna have
to go fight this war yeah right i'm not
gonna go have to go do it but very
rarely are the people say who say do it
the ones that are gonna have to go do it
mm-hmm well you know what's interesting
uh um emily there was a poll that showed
that american support for the no-fly
zone dropped once they were told what it
was
they were all they thought that like no
flight zone met don't fly there
and so that was 40 ford and then it
dropped to 25 when they said no you
might be shooting at russian planes and
that's called war i mean i okay i'm not
gonna belittle everyone that answered
that poll yeah because what i will say
is you know i can just speak for myself
that when i see those images
um my heart breaks and when i hear about
the children that have died and when i
see that people are starving and getting
shot while in line for bread and we you
know there are facts that are occurring
there are images that are undeniable
that we are seeing and those tear my
heart apart and so i just know that i i
do want to help i wish my tax dollars
would go to help i wish my
commander-in-chief would have acted like
one
a year ago
and actually deterred this guy because
here's the thing putin's not going to
stop until he has stopped and it's like
congressman walt said which is basically
that these vague comments that our
president keeps saying well he'll face
severe consequences and the like that
doesn't mean anything to putin so until
he meets american steel and still until
he meets any kind of steel he won't stop
uh but i guess that begs the question to
your point is well you know what at what
point is that line does that necessitate
american involvement because i think
what we've learned in history is that oh
it doesn't harm us yet it doesn't impact
us yet
then by the time it does
thousands of people have been killed
thousands of americans potentially have
been killed and to me as we're all
looking at this as humans or you know
half human like
when we're seeing human suffering i just
know that i want to help oh nice just
like say the dna test did prove i'm
totally human yes
that bigfoot thing was a gross lie
started by gut felt yes hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else